as David did say um I think it's not a
coincidence that there are quite a few
talks about testing uh from different
aspects uh personally this is a topic
that's uh very close to my heart because
I think that the gap between uh the
impact and how it can help help us build
more trustworthy reliable and efficient
machine learning pipelines and the state
of adoption of how far are we in in
front of are we doing it properly and
are we addressing this problem these
problems is quite a big gap and I think
that's why kind of now it's more and
more uh being heard of and thought of
and um
so I know maybe some of you saw a talk
title originally more about like focused
on evaluation we will talk also about
model evaluation just really in the
context of uh testing and how how to how
to do it um there so just shortly about
myself
um my name is
my background is mainly in research I
started in uh there's a in Israel in the
IDF there's a program called tarpio it's
um the the elite technological
leadership program so about 50 people
per year we do together a bachelor's
degree and lots of um and see like lots
of uh
um army Tech related areas and then each
go to different core areas and Lead
different aspects so personally I
started in the unit A200 or maybe some
of you are familiar with the name in
cyber research and Philip who's a very
close friend of mine from tarpio and
also my co-founder in deep checks was
the one that transitioned me to data
science and showed me the cool use cases
and really I got there working on some
relatively in the early days of data
science so I had the honor pleasure and
challenge of working on machine learning
models
um when it when kind of the organization
didn't yet know how to fully utilize it
so seeing the challenges of having the
users adopt trust them seeing the
challenges of really having like the
first time a machine learning model
replace what was previously done
manually by analysts and so forth and
that was a kind of one of the main
motivations of founding deep checks in
which we work on continuous validation
of machine learning models which is
really how to how to have them operate
properly throughout the life cycle of
the model and um well I'll talk at the
end just a bit more about what we do
you'll also see it Incorporated kind of
in a talk because this is a relatively I
would say most Hands-On talk in the
context of we're going to see Concepts
how to like what are the problems how to
utilize the how to solve or address them
and with various examples because we
also have quite a wide open source first
offering so also I'll show examples from
it which you can hopefully use
in your pipelines or be inspired by and
Implement them in a way uh that's
relevant for you and generally
personally about me I love training so
not only models
um you may see me maybe here some
morning uh going on a run or in some
more exotic locations kite Surf and
skiing and if you're ever around the Tel
Aviv area then it's likely to see me on
either my electrical or non-electrical
unicycle
um I will say that feel free if you have
any questions throughout okay you can
raise your hand I'll be happy to to take
questions and hopefully you'll have also
some time at the end I will say that the
office hours will be not directly after
because we have a short break so if not
feel free to catch me like I think it's
at um at four
um cool
so
um since we're going to talk about
testing in CI CD it mainly means that we
have two topics to cover and one is
testing and the other one is CI CD and
the connection between them and um let's
just Dive In
so
what happens to machine Learning Without
Foundation I think we've all seen lots
of examples these are just a few that
were published throughout recent years
from Trading glitches weird prices bias
problems
um glass doors Co being offered
positions in Glassdoor even though he's
obviously already working there and this
is just kind of the tip of the iceberg I
guess any data science practitioner that
I talk to that's uh more than a short
while in the field has usually examples
it's not necessarily always examples
that came to production it sometimes it
is and like losing uh thousands of
dollars or having some uh some uh
undesired uh predictions uh for example
bias but many times it just throughout
the research like some way part way
there a few weeks in you understand that
your data acquisition efforts were
problematic you have problematic labels
and it's really kind of throughout and
this is um so we're going to talk about
in the broader way some of it is also uh
uh in order for us not to have uh not to
be next in the titles
so
before we start though the concept of
testing is really not that new right I
mean in software it's for so long and
and um why don't we just do exactly the
same thing so while both machine
learning and uh like their software have
code involved it's really essentially
different
um three main differences which I think
help us understand why it's so Dynamic
and why the challenges we Face are
really um very different is the way it's
built so while in software you can see
okay what were the changes in code like
what did they actually change and um and
did I cover the area that I changed in
in machine learning everything basically
can change whether it's the data the
model
um the pipeline and
um that's it this also relates to the
fact that how do we even know what have
we covered when testing so while
coverage doesn't account for everything
in software but it does give us a great
clue of did we go through the different
paths and um and are there any any like
branches that we didn't in machine
learning what does it mean to cover am I
trying to if it's a neural network
obviously I'm not trying to cover like
the activations of the neural network
right that's like not really relevant
but am I trying to cover the input
distribution but it's basically infinite
so and not all of it is relevant either
so it's really hard to understand what
did like what are the areas which we
which remained unexplored let's say and
my favorite and the most troubling one
is that silent failures are very common
because if we had a problem anywhere in
our pipeline it's most likely that we
will still get a number being or numbers
being fed into our model and numbers as
output and while the machine learning
model doesn't come and say okay I got
some garbage and therefore like don't
rely on my output so it will it will uh
be failing just without telling us
so hopefully I mean I mean by by now I
guess um it's quite clear why you would
want to have uh a testing or automatic
testing methodology I think like the
main focus for me is why to act like why
to move uh transition yourself from the
part of yes testing is important and
relevant to how should I treat this in a
manner in order to
um make it serve me and like not the
other way around
um what I mean is no one really wants to
now take your time and write tests and
cover everything right but one for
example you have a very wide resource of
uh of relevant tests that are repeatable
that are for example organization wide
that are relevant for your domain and
now we just for example uh uh you just
kind of plug in your test and just run
the pipeline once it's automatic once
you don't have to every time actually
cover everything
um it makes it much more efficient maybe
to just kind of exemplify many times
when when users use um like the open
source tags like deep checks they they
are surprised that we find new issues
that they weren't aware of the reason
being that usually as a data scientist
you would like check the top five or ten
issues that you suspect
um obviously a few if you automatically
check like 25 issues it's likely that
you will find some some additional stuff
and
so we talked a bit about continuous
validation or testing so when should we
test
um if we look abstractly at a machine
learning Pipeline and this being the
research part from data ingestion
pre-processing training and evaluation
and after that we have the decision to
deploy and cicd which I'll touch upon
soon and uh the production area are
quick answer my quick answer is as soon
as possible like for example if we
started research and here we already
have our data we don't actually need to
wait for a model to validate the data or
if we split or we have a new data set
coming in we don't need the predictions
in order to check whether the drift like
whether there's a drift or a leakage or
changes like that so I'm going to talk
about like the notion of how does this
meet us and the the main thing is that I
think while machine learning
observability and monitoring and
production is very widely talked about
actually in the areas of cicd I feel
that in many places it's less developed
and that's kind of weird like finding
your is in production where you could
have actually caught them in cicd I'll
say that oh personally and in deep
checks that is actually what brought us
more towards research and cicd that many
of the problems that we found like
problems in the data we understood that
we should we didn't actually have to
wait here we could have caught them for
customers much earlier
um so what do we actually test so if we
if we take a even higher level of
abstraction the main phases are
everything that has to do with acquiring
the data and processing it training the
model and deploying it so if I try to
categorize what is relevant to be tested
in each of these we have data Integrity
um data distribution and model
evaluation
let's look at a few of the problems that
we can find in each of these phases
um so this is really just a few I'll
give a few examples and and go into them
um and then we'll see kind of how it all
connects
so just to show us that it's not only um
Junior data scientists that may have
these types of problems so this is
Andrew Ang's post from 2017 about uh
they had a new a new network for
diagnosing pneumonia and it had a great
performance and obviously got headlines
and everything was great
only if we look and thank you Santiago
for this recent tweet Santiago looked at
the initial article the paper that they
uh that they published and he's he
showed that there's 112
000 x-ray images on which um the data
was trained from 30 000 patients which
is fine right we can have like more than
one x-ray image per patient
if we look at the second part he said
the the original paper said it was
randomly split into
um two data sets eighty percent training
20 validation
um I see from your faces that yeah many
of you have noticed that this is a
problem we have here leakage between
train and test
um thankfully this was uh obviously
corrected sometime obviously afterwards
but this is a Stanford research group in
a paper from 2017 okay
um so this is one example of how and
where it can happen to anyone and later
we'll see also how we can catch it
um we'll go into various examples to
kind of give a bit more of uh a view so
here we have a loan model okay it's um
there's various metadata
um who is the person uh income where
they live so fourth and the model is
predicting whether or not to approve a
loan
um it's a classification model and here
we see 0.82 let's have a look at this
sample I I don't know if it's uh big
enough for sure there's quite like each
of is this feature and the value of the
feature and those of you that may have
noticed the United States was spelled
differently now
if for pipeline actually dealt with this
and we didn't normalize our data then
this would have been fixed but if it
hadn't then probably what would happen
at this phase would that let's say we do
one hot encoding right so United States
with a small s is a new category right
being a new category may be also much
less common and if the country which is
likely a significant feature as we can
see we get a completely different
um prediction so this is the problem you
call string mismatch and that's in the
area of data Integrity right because
it's nothing changed but but it's really
um it's really the data itself
another another different example and
here it's I would say somewhat a policy
or the construction of a data set I'm
not here saying what is the correct
answer what what you can see is that the
only difference is the sex of the person
while the prediction is different this
is something we would first of all want
to be aware of and probably want to
monitor verify and have a specific
policy about how we deal with these
types of things the thing is that if we
don't actually Define it or check for it
then it can go unnoticed until it gets
um some not very complementing titles
and obviously problems
and it's not only limited to so I I gave
a few examples from tabular data but
it's really all throughout obviously the
way to catch these types of problems is
a bit different but these problems exist
so I don't know those of you that are
familiar with uh this is a paper from
2016 called why should I trust you and
they had a great model for um like the
what they were trying to do was
distinguish between wolves and huskies
and the metrics of the model were really
really good okay it did a great great
job
um however when they inspected the
places in which it was wrong they did
notice uh some some uh pattern and that
is if we have a look at this example and
we can see that um the truth is Husky
and the prediction was wolf
does can you kind of uh does anyone have
a suspicion what's different yeah
snow right so the model did a great job
of learning the background and if it was
snowy it said um it said wolf and if it
wasn't it said husky now let's imagine
this camera or this algorithm being
deployed on a camera on one of the pools
for example or or generally like isn't
doing something uh rather than just
detecting the the background so this is
called shortcut learning and it exists
not only in Vision I'll here I'm just
sharing to show how it can look also in
a different place this is a a real uh
use case from a company which I won't
mention its name but I will mention that
they they worked for quite quite a while
on a like initial kind of model for
um what they had to do is they had
medical records and they had to extract
the symptoms which is obviously useful
in order to to see like the bottom line
for the doctors
and they built a great model that for
every like uh every few words it would
say whether it's a symptom or not a
symptom and we can see that generally it
seems that the performance is fine
um on the left we see where the model
predicted the symptom and on the right
we see where it's predicted or not
symptom basically it was right except
for this example I don't know if any of
you already noticed some pattern between
between the predictions if not I'll say
that the pattern is oh if it's three
words it's not a symptom the reason
being that the way that the way they can
they constructed the data set and they
actually noticed this only in production
after like after they put it in
production kind of as a shadow model for
for a while and they checked out its
performance they saw that it's really
really bad and then they understood that
the way they constructed the train data
set was they took
um for the for the like they had
obviously labeled symptoms and then they
had to have also known symptoms so so
without noticing they just took um three
word sections and uh obviously this made
the model not really learn anything
relevant
and continuing in NLP and seeing I'm
sure like different types of examples so
the concept of drift of course we have
different types of drift uh those of you
that were in the talk before I think you
discussed it a bit
um and the thing is it really obviously
drift and type of the data looks in one
way and in NLP a bit different and and
soon after I'll show how we deal with it
but in this case we see the word Twitter
and we see it's um prevalence over time
uh actually the red and the blue first
of all we see how it changes like uh in
ratio and specifically the red and the
blue are two different terms
um not only does this help us explain
that probably when we look here the
words Twitter is generally related to a
very different con context than than
when it was searched um in uh for
example here
and the other thing is that it's also
not necessarily
um even per specific time I mean even if
we retrain the model and say okay it
will learn the relevant context
even that's not necessarily everyone
because what we see here is uh
throughout the same time uh between
different demographies it was very
different okay so this does give us
understand that we have to really
understand like drill down and have a
more uh nuanced way of of understanding
what's relevant and how it affects us
so this is kind of to keep you and we'll
in a second we will see how how we um
deal with it so coming back to this
slides we did go over a few of these
problems that you see here and there are
many more and I think my for me I would
say that a main takeaway from the stock
is that
you really need to think about this
topic and mainly to think and build a
checklist of what is relevant for your
use case I would say that um a relevant
like in in software engineering we have
the notion of regression testing which
is okay if we had a problem previously
we make sure that we add a test for it
and then every new version for example
it will automatically be tested and and
we'll see that we don't recur so
obviously if you ever face a problem
make sure you add it to your checklist I
cannot recommend it for those of you
that also saw a picture of this site I
can recommend checking out our docs as I
said um since it's open source you can
really see a list of um like all the
different checks that we have and their
implementations you can get inspired
from there or add any additional ones
maybe more domain specific ones but
that's really the thing that once you
check for like 30 different problems the
likelihood of catching them much earlier
is much higher
and so without further Ado I'll just
show a bit how we deal or work with
these different concepts so as I said
deep checks is an open source package
um python package for testing machine
learning
and um
I'll describe our Concepts just because
it helps us kind of see how we go about
so a check is uh something that that
comes to validate a specific issue okay
so if I want to check that I don't have
a I have a duplicate data or string
mismatch or or feature drift so these
are all checks and in order to be able
to run the checks efficiently we have
something that's called The Suite so a
suite is just a list of checks a check
can have also a condition upon it so for
example if I don't want a drift above a
certain level I can add the condition
that the drift score isn't above X or if
I don't have want any duplicates then
the same so the basic concepts are
checks conditions and uh test Suites
and now kind of tracing back the
different problems we saw I'll show a
bit how we think about addressing these
and and finding them so we talked about
shortcut learning here I'm going over
the CV example but it's really kind of
the same for NLP
um
for for unstructured data and generally
we have we have the general we have the
um challenge of what do we actually
monitor right so we can look at
embeddings we can we can extract
different metadata from it so in this
case what you see here is really the
kind of a wolf versus husky a data set
and what we're doing is we're extracting
various what we call properties which is
metadata about the pictures so for
example things like
um the ratio things like if it's an
object detection class things uh object
action task things like the number of uh
the number of
um of labels like inside a picture the
size of them and lots of properties
which help us help us reach meaningful
insights upon it so in this case
um
if we look if we look at like different
properties we extracted things like
brightness things like uh colors that we
can see we can see that some of them
like this is a check that checks uh the
correlation between some of the
properties with the label okay so for
example the brightness of the picture is
somewhat indicative of what is the final
label or um the intensity of some of the
colors is also indicative so this
doesn't tell us necessarily that our
model has done shortcut learning but it
does tell us that there is some
correlation between between some
properties of the picture and the label
and therefore it would be something that
we want to validate is our data set
really represent like obviously a
solution here would be to just change
the structure of a data set right so if
we see that there are some aspects in
the data set which weren't uh built uh
optimally then we can adapt them so so
this is a data Integrity uh check as we
call it
string mismatch the example we saw
before with United States being uh big
and small so in this case we can really
just check that we don't have multiple
forms of the same words whether it's
special characters or anything like that
so here we just kind of see an example
of
um again it might it's not necessarily a
problem but it's in something we can
verify and make sure that nothing
throughout the pipeline kind of Mr
attention
um this is an example that I really like
because it's uh relevant in quite a lot
of contexts so the notion of how is our
model performing so for example if we
have uh demographic features or even not
necessarily demographic it can also be
in this example it's like we see various
um features that are related to
technical aspects so for example maybe
our performance is much better for
Android users than for iPhone and so
forth so what we do in uh like when look
when talking about model evaluation and
how how to really address it in a more
uh thorough way is checking the
performance throughout different
segments okay so in the case
specifically weak segments performance
what it does is it tries to find
sub-segments of the data in which the
model is performing much worse in this
case for example we can see that five
percent of the data is in a specific uh
URL length and titles and its
performance is um 0.96 so which is uh
much lower than the average performance
of 0.99
thank you
and a drift which is uh uh always a
loved one and in this case I mean drift
drift for unstructured data is uh always
an interesting Challenge and what you
see here is this is just um we see
embeddings from in this case from openai
and what we see in red is that test data
set and includes the train data set I
call them train and test but essentially
it can be any two data sets right it can
also be like uh my uh inference data
from yesterday and my inference data
from today or training data of the model
versus inferences and so forth but
anyway train test or any two data sets
and one way one way to distinguish that
we find very useful for drift especially
when it's like multivariate drift is we
train uh what we call a domain
classifier so we train our model and and
the target of the model is to um per
sample say whether this is a train
sample or is this a test sample okay so
the target is like which data set it
belongs to and the drift score which is
our overall classification of is this
drifted or not is how how good is this
model right because if my model is able
to distinguish between train and test
then probably I have a significant
enough difference between them or some
sort of multivariate drift or embedding
drift
um so this is also relevant for
multivariate drift for tabular data and
in this case what we can see is so the
drift score is derived from the domain
classifiers score and in this case we
see it's a high drift score if we try to
understand the drift score we can see it
okay so let's have a look we can like
buy the eye we can see that there are
really areas in which it's quite clear
whether this belongs to the train or to
the test but a good way to like let's
say okay so we have some drift what what
do we do now right so if we have a high
drift it means the domain classifier is
doing uh quite a good enough job and
what we can do is let's have a look at
the samples in which the domain
classifier is telling us these are like
quite highly related to the train or the
test so what the view we see now is the
predictions of the domain classifier so
very bright means it was very very much
convinced it belongs to one and very
dark like blue is uh to the other
this at this phase of course well one
thing we may want to do is um retrain
the other thing we may want to do is try
to explore and understand like what is
the difference and in this case
um what we do is look at additional like
slices and see a correlation so for
example if we look at the topics of
these different areas we can see that
the drift is really related to various
in this case it's like a tweet related
um comment so we can see that they come
from different topics and then this
helps us kind of understand a bit more
the drift and what we actually want to
do with it
um if there are any questions then this
is a good time
not getting
stuck in the infinite Loop of like
I must get my classifier model better to
know if there is a drift like how do you
not get stuck in the world of like
trying to get that model extreme
extremely good or trying to write a
model to test that model like that just
seems redundant so like what are like
rules of thumb that you guys use to say
like okay enough this is
right so generally speaking I'd say that
like the main usage of the classifier
model for example for um finding a
multivariate drift we also like are we
don't in any sense want to like optimize
and for example improve it by five
percent like it's really not relevant
that like the interesting insight for us
is let's say is there data there like
for example I guess all of you have had
the opportunity of trying to build a
machine learning model for somewhere
where there's really really um no signal
okay so if there's very low to look to
no signal it's not really relevant to
you know try and improve we're really
interested in can we in relatively
simplistic manners find a good model and
if we can I think like that I would say
that the more challenging part is really
going from uh okay a domain classifier
gives us a strong signal to how can we
understand the signal as easy as
possible and not not necessarily okay is
you know is there like is the domain
classifier giving us a AUC of um zero
like Roc over 0.6 or 0.63 so um because
it's really on a Model where we're using
it only for uh diagnosis for purposes
like as you're building it you're like
oh I'm spending more than six hours on
this
specifically the main like the the
multivariate drift we do we do it
relatively simplistically because we
don't need to do any like feature
engineering for example we use the
embeddings as this or we use the
features as is so it's not we we
basically spend zero time like you can
check specifically we have multivariate
drift of feel free to check out that
check you'll see both its implementation
and an example and uh yeah and we just
like um build for example uh a random
Forest so that's like an impossibly
iterate like minimally
um so I will see this in in action and I
think the like the takeaway uh in my in
my of this demo is that if this is
something that's super easy to actually
run and Implement then the motivation of
actually did it start or not yet okay
then the motivation of actually
implementing this is uh is much higher
so what we see here is just running what
what I said before we have a suite so a
suite is a list of checks okay I have I
prepare the the demo because I don't I
couldn't do it here live so we're going
to work on uh this is a Lending Club
data so it's about loans okay and what
you see here is just like uh various
data about the loan and um this is the
train test validation so I'm just
splitting the data into train okay so if
it's in June in July it's in a training
data set and if it's in August it's in
the test data set and now the only thing
we actually need to do in order to run
deep checks is to create a data set a
data set is a very straightforward
object what it has is
um it just contains the data okay so we
can see we have a train DF that's a data
frame with the data and same for the
test and the only additional thing we
need in order to actually understand
what's going on in your data is the
columns metadata so for example
um do we have a label column and what's
its name so in this case the the label
is the loan or do we have a date time or
an index and categorical features we can
either just like not State them then
they will be inferred um automatically
which is a bit less accurate or we can
just give a list of them and basically
that's it so when once we just find the
The Columns and created a data set we
can run whether it's a check that's like
a single one or a suite which is a list
of checks so in this case we're running
the train test validation suite and the
idea that kind of again if testing is
easy then we'll do it um uh happily I
guess
because they will save us uh problems
for later on so what you see here is the
output of the train test Suite so the
output is um because it's a built-in you
can also customize this video we'll see
it a bit later but because it's a
built-in Suite we have some like default
conditions okay so in this case we see
that there's something that didn't pass
okay what didn't pass we found leaked
dates so if you remember before I said
that we split like June July and August
the problem is that there were there was
data from two years so if I have test
data samples from 2017 to 2018 but I
have also training data from 2018
obviously this is a problem kind of
resembling what we saw before just this
is like a date leakage problem
um so in this case like what we'll do
now is
I think I pressed it by mistake yeah I
did
so what we'll do now is um is we'll fix
the problem by just like saying Okay so
let's just take training data to be now
that we are aware so 2017 and test data
to be 2018 and then we just like
recreate again the data sets and
um with the same columns metadata and
run it
and here we'll
we'll see that we don't have a date
leakage anymore but we may have
different problems so in this case like
we have a new category like a value of a
category that's only in the test set so
there's a feature
um called uh address state
which was only in the test set so
obviously our model if we train our
model on this it will have no additional
data about it and we can also find here
yeah it's a bit harder when the demo is
uh it's not live and we also see here uh
a multivariate drift okay so so here
this is kind of the same mechanism as
before we're training a domain
classifier and in this case we both see
the drift score and and when we scroll
down we can see what are the main
features so what we take is the feature
importance from the domain classifier
and we can see that um features
features such as interest rate
and um
are the are the main contributors
interest rate and the other one is uh is
the loans great
now these are just a few checks if we
just like look at all the others we can
see that there's many additional checks
again we can customize this but just as
an example if we look individually at
each of the of the features the drift
isn't that high but when we look at it
multivariate way
um there was a big drift so this is an
example of running a suite and the idea
is really that you can write your own
checks
um through deep checks or or like
directly separately and we can also just
run a single check so for example if we
want a multivariate drift we just import
it
and in this case we can add a condition
we can also just run it as is and this
doesn't have to only be used like we can
also use the same display data like
before but since many times in this
relates to the part of the CI CD we want
the machine to parse it right so we just
have like the value and we don't have to
necessarily look at the graphs we can
really look at all of the outputs like
if it is in this case the the score of
the domain classifier and so forth
um so the idea is really to have lots of
checks easy to run and very easy to
customize and also a parse and code
and for the last thing like what we see
what we see here is how you write a
custom Suite so instead of using our
suite we can we can just like choose any
checks we want
write them together with a name and then
created a suite and just and just run it
so
I think we've covered quite elaborately
testing and how how do we connect this
to cicd
so cicd is a concept of always being
able to integrate and like continuous
integration and continuous delivery or
continuous deployment um both terms
exist and and they're valid and the
concept is really the ability to always
maintain a working code base a working
like let's say we did a small iteration
and we still want everything to work so
the CI part is the part of building
testing merging and the CD is is we also
want to be able to frequently deploy
um stable stable uh
um stable uh versions
so this brings us here and really the
notion of doing it before deployment
automatically helps us build more
trustworthy uh models
um on a continuous basis so if we look
generally at testing and like the
differences between the different phases
I would say that in research we would
want to run it manually right whenever
for example whenever we get new data
whenever we train the new model we want
to compare between models in cicd we
want to do it upon the trigger so it's
either a trigger of deployment a trigger
of merge whichever trigger you want but
like when we Define and in production we
want to do it in an ongoing manner
inspecting the results and research we
want to analyze and understand in cicd
usually you would want to be able to
very easily approve like go no go
um uh if if relevant automatically then
better and in production we would want
to be we want to be alerted as early as
possible
and I would say that the main goal in
research is to have us avoid problems
and find them as early as possible and
cicds to prevent it kind of last moment
before we before we jump into production
and in production is to detect the
problem as early as possible
so I'll dive in a bit here because I
think the notion of testing and
automated testing really this is where
it comes to place and this is it's like
I had a conversation with Emily those of
you that were in her session maybe
before and I think that while in some
way we we reached like kind of diff
somewhat different uh emphasis of who
should test and where should we test I
think we do both agree of the concept
that
um the like in the places where it's
possible to have inside your process
sufficient testing it will save lots of
uh time especially in this case if like
for example the data scientist actually
has a big part in defining the tests and
uh being able to make sure they they run
properly just a few examples of why I
think like or examples of where this is
super relevant so when we retrain every
day we obviously need automated testing
in order to make sure that the data
didn't drift uh drastically when we have
the same model but being trained like on
very different data so for example if
you're an ISP V and you have like a
model for each of your deployments for
each of your clients so maybe it's the
same model but you know it's retrained
on different data you want to make sure
that all of them are fine and not like
uh you don't want to manually test them
um another good example is when you want
to compare between models or decide like
okay which one of them is better kind of
you know in a wider manner so we have an
automatic pipeline that trains five
models and we want to just choose
between them in an automated manner when
we have complex pipelines such as many
data sources coming in and probably the
data team didn't notify us that they
changed the API and now the calibration
is like of the feature it's not no
longer between one and three it's
between 1 and 23. obviously our model
will continue to work but that feature
will be irrelevant so the more complex
the pipeline the more places that there
are I think a classic example which
happens a lot is that the process the
like processing pipeline was updated but
only in testing or only only in the
inference sorry you're only in the
training and they're suddenly like we we
discovered this usually only when it's
actually in production and when we want
to really like drill down and check for
example lots of metrics business metrics
data science metrics and we really want
to make sure that it at least exceeds
the threshold for all of these metrics
and this is something that's very
tedious to do manually and will probably
um not actually do it so these are lots
of places where I see CI CD being
gradually more adopted and kind of still
not there and that there are many more
but these are just a few I wanted to
mention
and when we look about implementing CI I
would say that there are a few kind of
key roles and one thing is what does it
integrate with so uh classically it
would be either with Source control like
a GitHub gitlab or with workflow
management such as airflow and what are
the triggers so maybe we'd also want to
be able to trigger it manually upon
every commit upon every merge and so
forth
what are the resources from which which
it takes right so if you're for example
working with uh model versioning so
maybe you would want to take the
artifact from there or wherever you
store your data and your model and so
forth so be able to be very flexible
about working with uh with the resources
and and what it actually runs on
be able to have a fail pass status this
relates to the like automatically uh
knowing if if it works or not
and um also being able to save like
previous versions and comparing between
them
so if I summarize CI and for testing
machine learning models it's running
tests on like predefined resources on
predefined triggers and while this seems
quite I know for I think for many times
for data scientists this seems like a
kind of far away Notions I think
actually implementing this is uh super
easy I will give an a kind of short
end-to-end example of how this actually
looks and this can be either again
implemented those of you that are
interested I'd be happy to also uh talk
like we do have this is just kind of a
POC which we also have an alpha for but
but it's also very easy to implement it
yourself and I think it's really the
concept of how how we actually run this
so this is like a end-to-end kind of how
it works so what we see here is
yeah is it working cool so essentially
what we want to configure is is two
things one is what are the resources we
run on okay so like a trained data set
the test data set the model and the
other thing is
is what do we what do we test okay so
what like what do we actually want to
run now you'll see this is in this case
we put it like inside the dot deep
checks folder and this is a simple yaml
configuration file so for each of these
assets we say like okay from from where
do you take it so whether if you want to
take like a built-in Suite so this is
like okay deep check sweet State
Integrity or if we want a custom Suite
like we saw before it's just defined in
simple code and this is the name of the
file and the name of um of the actual um
uh sweet which you can see there so
what how does the configuration of these
assets look like so we have here a file
in which we can really um like get the
training data set
um the test data set basically what we
do is we just read it from wherever okay
so here if it's in S3 or from ml flow or
loaded from wherever we want so we load
the data set and for the model itself we
can do one of two we can either load
like a pre-trained model or we can have
the CI actually trigger also the
training and then we save aside like the
the model and then we can just use the
one that we trained here also um later
on so in this case what we're like
showing here is that we did some
improvements okay for the CI for the for
the pipeline and many I guess many of
you have like did you ever change uh
model to be
um like some of the processing to be in
numpy in order for it to be more
efficient some of the processing so we
did that and we like improved the
inference time of the model okay so here
I just like updated kind of the in the
background the new commit of improving
model inference time and I'm just like
uh committing and Publishing the the new
the new code
and now if we go into the into the
GitHub we'll see that there's like a new
a new Branch with pushes a minute ago
and we create a pull request right
because we just updated the model and we
want to stay always uh always updated
and we just um open the pr and now you
can see that
um we're going to run the required
checks from the dot deep checks
configuration file and we can see the
test just like any other test in
progress
um so we're just waiting to see the
results
and now we can see that the checks have
failed which is good to know before we
actually deploy or merge it and in this
case again this is like a recent POC we
can see more more details in the Deep
check CI so what we see here essentially
is just the output of a suite so we see
that there are some checks that failed
like a train test performance and Roc
reports so
we can see that there's a really drastic
change between the performance on the
train data sets and on the data test
data set and even more troubling the The
ROC is kind of 0.5 okay so it does seem
that something is super wrong with our
model I'll just like jump a bit forward
so if we go back here to our code we can
see that this is a simulation so what I
did here was I uh like converted it into
numpy and basically I don't know if it
happened to you uh for me it happened it
was a super annoying bug of um because
because of the numpy conversion what
happens was that the indices were
actually lost and then like the labels
and the samples were no longer actually
correctly correlated
and in this case what we see is like so
again this just kind of symbolizes what
happened in the background but the real
the real error is that we had a
different inference pipeline than our
training pipeline in this case what I'll
do now is just like comment out this
line that resembles that problem and uh
and just commit the the correction
yeah so this is the new file
and committing it to GitHub
and now if we come back here and we
refresh we can see that there was a new
a new fix
and that all checks have passed so if we
actually go and see all the details or
we can see it also from here
we can see that our CI ran again
and now everything has passed if we want
to really like for example compare
between various models and different
branches so here we're just looking at
previous runs and uh in this case this
is like the previous commit okay so we
can really see that in this case we had
a degradation of 50 between the trade
and test metrics and for example
um on the current one we can really see
a very big uh difference right so
basically uh we fixed the problem and uh
now we can go ahead and uh really
like
since everything is fine we can now
merge and if we save the side like the
model asset we can also use it uh in
production and um so this is really an
example of how to how to integrate it we
have been seeing uh in deep checks quite
elaborate elaborate usage of uh of it
for for cicd related use cases because I
think that that's where really the the
automation now gives quite a lot of
power of uh avoiding problems so we
talked a bit about testing
um mentioned some specific types of
problems and saw how they how they recur
throughout different types of data and
use cases
how it's relevant throughout the life
cycle so we didn't touch that much uh
monitoring but uh but obviously there we
just have to do it on an ongoing basis
and talked a bit about uh testing with
deep checks if I just add another
sentence or two about us so really what
we do is we work in the area of
continuous validation we have um open
source offerings basically for all of
these fields actually for the monitoring
one we're going to release it just in a
few weeks so um if that's relevant for
you stay tuned
um and well we have also like more
managed offerings for for those that um
it's relevant
and
that's a bit about us um feel free to
scan the QR for more details about me
um I'll be happy to connect on LinkedIn
I would want to say like many of the
tests and problems and things that we
actually implemented is lots of things
to the data science Community to
feedback to feature requests and that's
one of the things why it's really really
amazing to work on a on an open source
product that is both relevant and gives
value to a place where I think is most
critical and really helps make the
amazing value of machine learning work
better in uh and wider spread and those
of you that have a GitHub account I'd
love to if you can give us a story it's
really important for for open source
projects and um yeah I think that's it
I'll be happy I mean think there is a
break now so if anyone has any questions
feel free to to come now or also well
later for for the office hours
thank you
[Music]